THE HOUSING COMMITTEE IS NOW
STARTING AS A SUBCOMMITTEE. WE
WILL HEAR ONE BILL. IT IS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WICKS BILL. IT
IS AB 2243. MISS WICKS, PROCEED.
THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBER. SO I HAVE A BILL AB
2243. THIS IS ESSENTIALLY
COLLOQUIALLY REFERRED TO AS AB
2011 2.0, SINCE THAT BILL HAS
BEEN IN EFFECT OVER THE LAST
YEAR, WE HAVE HAD PEOPLE COME
FORWARD WITH US REQUESTING
SPECIFIC CLEANUP, MAKING SURE
THAT THE BILL CAN BE IMPLEMENTED
EFFECTIVELY AND IN ITS MOST
USEFUL FORMAT. IN ADDITION TO
THAT, WE ARE ATTEMPTING TO
EXPAND THE SCOPE OF WHERE IT CAN
BE USED, WE'VE MADE SOME
AMENDMENTS WORKING WITH SENATOR
CABALLERO TO ENSURE THAT THERE'S
CONFORMITY WITH THE WORK, GOOD
WORK THAT SHE HAS DONE IN
HOUSING AS WELL. SO THOSE
AMENDMENTS ESSENTIALLY REFLECT
THAT. THE AMENDMENTS THAT ARE IN
FRONT OF YOU TODAY TAKE OUT THE
OFFICE CONVERSION COMPONENT OF
THE BILL AND BRING CONFORMITY TO
SB SIX AND AB 2011. IN TERMS OF,
ITS EXPANDED SCOPE, IN TERMS OF
THE LABOR LANGUAGE THAT CAN BE
USED AND BRING BACK THE WIDTH OF
THE STREETS TO WHAT IT WAS
ORIGINALLY IN AB 2011. THAT'S
IT. IT'S PRETTY STRAIGHTFORWARD.
AND WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT AS
WE PASS THESE LAWS THAT THEY
ACTUALLY CAN BE EFFECTIVE AND
CAN BE USED. AND SO WE'RE SEEING
GREAT SUCCESS WITH AB 2011, BUT
WE WANT TO EXPAND ITS SCOPE. SO
WITH THAT I WOULD RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. GREAT. DO
YOU HAVE A KEY WITNESS? I MEAN,
WE CAN MAKE THIS QUICK, BUT, YOU
CAN BE BRIEF. YEP. SENATOR
STEPHEN SANDLER WITH BROWN
STEIN, ON BEHALF OF THE HOUSING
ACTION COALITION. WE'RE A PROUD
SPONSOR FOR THIS LEGISLATION.
OUR PRIORITIES ARE BUILDING MORE
HOUSING AT ALL INCOME LEVELS.
AND SUPPORTING THE WORKERS WHO
BUILD THAT HOUSING. THIS IS A
GREAT BILL, AND WE ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT. GREAT. DANNY CURTIN,
CALIFORNIA CONFERENCE OF
CARPENTERS. WE SUPPORT THE BILL,
OF COURSE. THANK YOU FOR
RECOGNIZING THE NEED FOR
IMPROVING THE WAGES AND THE
HOUSING AND CONSTRUCTION
INDUSTRY ACROSS THE BOARD,
BECAUSE IT IS A TWO TWO SIDED
COIN, LACK OF HOUSING AND LACK
OF INCOME. AND WE RECOGNIZE THAT
I'M GOING TO LEAVE THE LAND USE
TO THE PEOPLE WHO KNOW WHAT
THEY'RE TALKING ABOUT, BECAUSE
I'M WAY OUT OF THAT. AND THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. WE SUPPORT THE
BILL. THANK YOU. NOW THE REST
ARE METOOS. MADAM CHAIR. SCOTT
GOVERNOR, ON BEHALF OF THE
CONSTRUCTION EMPLOYERS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT. PROBABLY
FOR MANY DAYS IS WITH LIGHTHOUSE
PUBLIC AFFAIRS ON BEHALF OF
CIVIC WEALTH SPUR SANDHILL
PROPERTIES AND THE CALIFORNIA
BUILDING INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT. BROOKE PRITCHARD, ON
BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA YIMBY IN
SUPPORT. MARINA ESPINOSA WITH
THE CALIFORNIA HOUSING
CONSORTIUM IN SUPPORT. BOB
NAYLOR, ON BEHALF OF FIELDSTEAD
AND COMPANY. THAT'S HOWARD
AHMANSON JR IN ORANGE COUNTY.
PHILANTHROPIST. THANK YOU.
GREAT. ANY OTHER SUPPORTERS?
OKAY. DO WE HAVE OPPOSITION? ANY
OPPOSITION IN THE ROOM? ALL
RIGHT. CAN WE ESTABLISH QUORUM
NOW? NOW WE'RE MISSING. OKAY.
ALL RIGHT, WE CAN'T TAKE A
MOTION. BECAUSE WE'RE IN A
SUBCOMMITTEE, BUT WE WILL BE
ABLE TO AS SOON AS WE HAVE A
QUORUM, THOUGH I MAY, LET'S. I'M
GOING TO. I MAY TAKE A RECESS
BECAUSE THERE'S SO MANY OTHER
COMMITTEES RIGHT NOW. UNLESS I
CAN GET TWO MORE PEOPLE IN THE
ROOM AND AT LEAST TAKE THE
MOTION. YEAH. CATHERINE, DON'T
LEAVE QUITE YET. DON'T LEAVE
YET. LET ME JUST SEE IF I CAN
GET SOME TWO PEOPLE QUICKLY IN
THE ROOM. IF I CAN, THEN WE'LL
ACT. AND IF I CAN'T, WE'LL
RECESS. OKAY DOES ANYBODY WANT
TO HELP ME GET SOMEBODY ELSE IN
HERE? YEAH. I'M LOOKING, CORTESE
IN THE BUILDING. MENGIBAR. I'M
GOING TO GO BACK OVER THERE.
CORTESE. MENGIBAR AND, PADILLA.
OKAY. YEAH. I'LL TEXT, CORTESE
AND PADILLA. WE COULD FACETIME
THEM ALL.
OKAY. I DON'T KNOW.
IF.
ANYONE.
SHOULD BE UP THERE. HAPPY ENDING.
OKAY IF THERE WON'T BE 2102, HOW
MANY MORE SPEAKERS? YOU KNOW
WHAT? WELL I THINK. I REALLY
BELIEVE THAT. I AGREE. OKAY I'M
NOT SURE ABOUT THAT. AND THEY'RE
SO GRATEFUL FOR ALL THE SUPPORT.
YEAH. YEAH YEAH. TOMORROW. BUT
RIGHT NOW WE HAVE TO RESPOND.
OKAY. CAN YOU JUST SAID THEY
WOULD LIKE. TO HAVE A SECOND
ANNOUNCEMENT FOR THE. 5700. DO
YOU WANT TO MAKE. THAT. YEAH.
YEAH WE HAD GABBY COME OUT. IT
WAS REALLY FUN, ACTUALLY. YEAH.
YEAH. ONE WORD. NO. NO, IT'S A
WICKS. BILL. JUST SAY I. IT'S
ALWAYS JUST REFLEXIVE. I YEAH.
YEAH JUST ONE RUN AWAY FROM ONE
MORE. OKAY COME ON. I THINK
EVERY ONE OF THESE PEOPLE IN
THIS TOWN. I DON'T KNOW. I THINK
ALL OF THOSE MÁS. ALL RIGHT,
LET'S CALL THE ROLL. LOOK AT
THAT BLAZER. OH MY GOODNESS.
AMAZING. LET'S ESTABLISH A
QUORUM. LOOK AT THAT. LET'S
ESTABLISH QUORUM. SENATOR
SKINNER. I'M HERE. SKINNER.
PRESENT. OKAY SHAKESPEARE.
SHAKESPEARE. PRESENT. CABRERA
CABRERA. PRESENT. CORTEZ.
MENGIBAR. HERE. MENGIBAR.
PRESENT. PADILLA. CIERTO. UMBERG
UMBERG. PRESENT. WAHAB I MOVED
THE BILL. WE'LL HAVE PRESENT.
ALL RIGHT. WE HAVE A MOTION. THE
MOTION IS THAT SB? IT'S NOT SB,
IT'S AB 2243 BE REFERRED OR
RETURNED TO THE SENATE FLOOR FOR
CONSIDERATION, LET'S DO A ROLL
CALL. OH, OF COURSE. OR ASK IF
SHE DID CLOSE. ANYBODY HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS? GREAT. OKAY. THANK
YOU FOR HAVING ME FOLLOW THE
RIGHT PROCEDURE. NOW WE WILL
VOTE ON AB 2243. THE MEASURE BE
RETURNED TO THE SENATE FLOOR.
OKAY. ROLL CALL. SENATOR
SKINNER. SKINNER. AYE. OKOBOJI.
BLAKE. SPEAR. AYE. BLAKE. SPEAR.
AYE. CABALLERO. CABALLERO. AYE.
CORTEZ MENGIBAR. PADILLA SATO.
UMBERG. I UMBERG. I WAHAB.
WAHAB. I THAT'S 5 TO 0. IT'S NOT
OUT YET. NO. NOT YET. YET. OKAY
THAT BILL IS ON CALL. WE'LL WAIT
FOR ONE MORE MEMBER OR TWO, AND,
THEN WE'LL CLOSE. THANK YOU.
VERY.
PORTANTINO THANK YOU. ESTÁ.
BEALL. PRESIDENT IS NOT HERE
THIS MORNING. YES. VERY SAD. I
KNOW NOTHING MOVES ME. I'M A
KNOW NOTHING. OKAY THAT'S FINE.
ESPECÍFICAMENTE KI¾M. ALTHOUGH I
DON'T BELIEVE I WASN'T AWARE.
WICKS. YEAH.
YEAH NO, I AGREE. I KNOW IT'S
LIKE THE SIGN SAYS IT ALL.
CAFFEINE OKAY. ALL RIGHT. I
DON'T KNOW. OH, I REALLY THOUGHT
I SHOULD SPEAK. I'M NOT. LET'S
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. THAT'S
ON AB 2243 OKOBO CORTEZ MENJIVAR.
PADILLA. PADILLA I SATO. THANK
YOU. THANK. EFFICIENCY. OKAY.
OKAY ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU GUYS.
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT. SO AND THE
ONLY PEOPLE WE DIDN'T HAVE WERE
MR. CORTEZ. IF MR. CORTEZ IS ON
HIS WAY, I'LL HOLD THE ROLL, AND
THEN I'LL. I THINK I WAS GOING
TO. YEAH. SO. OKAY. I'LL SEE
YOU. OKAY, I'M GOING TO. I'M
HOLDING THE ROLL FOR MR. CORTEZ.
BECAUSE I HAVE TO GO VOTE IN
BUDGET. YES SO, MR. I'M SORRY.
WHAT DID YOU SAY? SATO WOULD
LIKE TO COME IN AND VOTE NO ON
THE BILL. WELL, HE'S GOT TO GET
HERE QUICK BECAUSE I'M NOT
HOLDING IT. SO JUST TELL HIM. I
WOULD BLAKESPEAR UCBCP.
OKAY. ACTUALLY.
ALL RIGHT. WE WILL CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. SENATOR COBA
CORTEZ. CORTEZ. AYE MANJU SATO.
OKAY I DON'T HAVE TO TELL SATO
STAFF THAT I AM CLOSING THE ROLL
BECAUSE I HAVE TO BE AT TWO
OTHER COMMITTEES. SO IF YOU
COULD LET THEM KNOW THAT RIGHT
NOW, I WILL LITERALLY WAIT THREE
MINUTES. AND THAT IS IT. THAT'S
RIGHT. HE CAN ALWAYS VOTE NO ON
THE FLOOR. I'M GOING TO SET MY
TIMER. IT'S LIKE WHAT YOU DO
WITH LITTLE KIDS. MY
GRANDDAUGHTER, SHE GOES, DO YOU
HAVE NANA? DO YOU?
ALL RIGHT. WE WILL CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. OKAY. JUST VOTE.
CURRENT VOTE IS 7 TO 0. SENATOR
OCHOA BOGH I. OKOBOJI. AYE. 8 TO
0. OKAY, GREAT. WE'VE GOT. WE'RE
HOLDING FOR ONE MORE. TWO
MINUTES AND 30S. WHAT? HE'S ON
THE STREET. HE'S COMING ACROSS
THE STREET. OH, I KNOW HE IS. I
KNOW HE IS. ALL RIGHT. THAT,
YES, YES. THANK YOU, AB 2243.
THE VOTE IS 8 TO 0. SO WE WILL
CLOSE THE RULES. THAT BILL IS
OUT. IT'S RETURNED TO THE SENATE
FLOOR, AND THE HOUSING COMMITTEE
IS NOW ADJOURNED.